a fight between passengers in a flight  attendant has resulted in another black  eye for the airline industry hey hey but  this is Facebook video of the incident  that happened on Friday on a fight that  was getting ready to take off from San  Francisco to Dallas the employee is  accused of taking a stroller from the  woman seen crying at the beginning of  the video and hitting her with it  narrowly missing the child she was  carrying another Pesa passenger then got  up and confronted a flight attendant  American says it is investigating the  incident  the airline released this statement  quote the actions of our team member  captured here do not appear to reflect  patience or empathy to values necessary  for customer care in short we are  disappointed by these actions the  employee has since been removed from  duty the incident comes nearly two weeks  after a man was violently dragged off a  United Airlines flight